resilient opportunistic creatively
rather persistent
[Music]
you know you have to be prepared for the
kind of events in your research that
there's not really predictable and you
have to be pretty resilient to
unexpected things happening and also
opportunistic when things do occur that
and really what you planned but to kind
of be creative and recognize that there
are things that you can do that maybe
weren't what your initial hypothesis in
your research would you know that said
you also have to be rather persistent in
pushing through the research because
often the answers won't come right away
[Music]